الانتقادات والمتبادله بين وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تعود لفتره لكن معركه سوليدار
الجاجاتها بعد اعلان انتصارات منفصله
بتوقيتات مختلفه روسي على ما يبدو استدركت
سريعا خطا قد يغذي النزاع المتصاعد وصححته
باشاده نادره بشجاعه عناصر فاجنر في
المعركه كما نفى الكرام لان وجود اي
خلافات مع فاجنر بل اكثرها ضمن اشاعات
ومحاولات تلاعب بالمعلومات يجريها طبعا
الخصوم
وزعم ان النساء لا يتعدى المجال الاعلامي
وان كلى طرفين اي الجيش الروسي وفاجن
مهمات مشتركه ورغم ان الكلام لن اكد معرفه
الشعب الروسي بهويه ابطاله الا ان اشاهدت
رئيس ببطولات قواته منفصله لا تزال
متواصله حيث شدد على استقلال القوه
وخدوعها
رباط الشرس وتمرسها بالقتال واضاف ان
عناصره يحققون كل الاهداف بصوره مستقله
لامتلاكهم الطائرات والمدفعيه والمدرعات
كما لفت الى اهميه نظام القياده الذي تم
تطويره بشكل تام وفق تعبيره في انتقاد
مبطن طبعا للقياده العسكريه العليا
الروسيه المتهمه بقله التنسيق
[موسيقى]